this this event is sponsored by Public
Square if you guys want to help win the
culture war and support businesses that
support our values download the Public
Square app check out businesses in your
area I really do mean it we were driving
back from dinner and Luke is in the back
of the car and he goes Kevin McCarthy
was just removed and I was like no no no
no no no wait wait wait wait like I'm
not seeing where you seeing that where
you seeing that he's like no it happened
and then we see the video that it's done
the for the first time in history Matt
has it's it's a stake in the heart of
the vampire it's it's the corporate
lobbyists it's the machine 82% according
to Gallup in the latest poll disapprove
of what Congress does and these members
of Congress are just like yeah we'll
keep doing what we're doing apparently
that's working it's working for them but
it's not for us so amazing work man
thank
[Applause]
you I guess the question is you know
what next uh if you if I I I don't want
to you know also we've got a bunch of
other amazing individuals on on the
stage as well and I also want to mention
we had James O'Keefe on the culture War
podcast this morning that's right that's
right and James was served a cease and
desist within an hour of the show
rapping it's not joke get sued a
lot so what next how's it going guys
yeah who's going to be the next speaker
what are we up against what do we do I
uh first let me just say the last time I
was in a room with hundreds of people
they did not like me as much so it is
good to be home in the great state of
Florida
[Applause]
so I I wish we didn't have to come to
this I wish we would have a budget but
there is a reason the actions in
Washington DC are hollowing out the soul
of this country because there's been an
Exquisite system designed where no one
is really responsible for the spending
or the efficacy or even the value that
government action has in all of your
lives because since the mid90s we have
been governed by either Omnibus spending
bill or continuing resolution which is
just a fancy way to say one up or down
vote on how the entire government runs
and they design it so that they back
people up against shutdown politics and
the fear that veterans might not get
benefits or the military might not get
paid and then they use that centralized
power to to Really feed an ecosystem and
an economy of corruption and here's how
it works if you can get the smallest
group of people to be able to dictate
the largest number of outcomes then the
special interests can go and buy those
people off and put their priorities
above what would be best for the
American people and it happens time and
time again and it is the reason we sit
at top a $33 trillion debt and what does
that mean for families right now the the
average American family is spending $700
more every month for the exact same
goods and services that you got last
year and in
99% of American counties the average
income will not support home ownership
so this debt that government has built
supporting non-efficacious programs
programs that don't even get reviewed
they just get reauthorized and increased
and sent on down the road that what
that's costing us is an ownership
Society where we own our land and our
homes and the choices that we make about
our own health care and the choices we
make about where uh our kids go to
school they want to take ownership away
and make everyone more and more reliant
on a system that is less and less
valuable and so while there's much work
to do and I'm sure we'll talk about that
this evening I know this I disrupted a
at least a billion doll corrupt economy
of political
favors and here's
how Kevin McCarthy has raised like a
billion dollars in special interest
money it is a remarkable feat but the
only way you really get to pay back the
favors is through these bills that are
thousands of pages and cover all these
areas where there's no individual
scrutiny because if you're the right
lobbyist that's given the millions of
dollars the hundreds of thousands of
dollars well then maybe you can count on
the fact that your program will be saved
that there won't be anything that'll
really get in the way of its continued
uh life indefinitely and now on K Street
where all the lobbyists have their
offices in Washington DC people are
holding a billion dollars worth of IUS
that are worth about as much as
Confederate money when Lee surrendered
the sword at aptic
Courthouse you love to
hear so that's uh man that it's it's
been an amazing week I mean I come back
and I'm just like what a good day what a
what a good day to see the Beast
groaning in agony
but uh oh to be honest uh Tim kind of
slapped the roof of the car and said
yeah that's true I did I was
laughing I was manically laughing I was
like the Joker in that car like just
with excitement because it's it's his
it's history and uh uh you know beyond
just what we're seeing with your fight
in Congress it feels it feels to me and
I assume it feels to a lot of people
that for the longest time we have tried
to be active in in our Civic duties we
have tried to voice and express our
opinions but every single time it turns
out that the people who tell us they're
going to bring us hope or change end up
getting in joining the machine and then
leaving us behind and it's like we're
not saying anything at all and so part
of I think what uh creates this e
ecosystem of independent podcasters uh
activist speakers and what ignited so
many people behind Donald Trump was that
finally we're starting to hear people
who as Michael Moore said rather
accurately represented a human Molotov
cocktail into a system that we were sick
and tired of now of course the system
doesn't like it when we throw Molotov
cocktails figurative figuratively I'm
referring to we're not antifa here they
don't they don't like it when we throw
that through their windows and so we end
up seeing recoiling of the machine of
the special interests Matt you posted a
a a photo of yourself over K Reeves head
with all the guns pointed at you and uh
and to throw it to James O'Keefe as well
this guy's been sued you know more times
than I have
birthdays they're they're coming after
us so I suppose my my question just to
anybody who wants to to to to jump in is
what's the bigger picture that we're up
against right now we all have these
these different individual fights but
what's the bigger picture I
guess I I think it's like um our our
nation our Consciousness has like a
parasite so it's I don't want to destroy
it it's we have to somehow extricate the
parasite without harming the host um
maybe I think hydrogen fuels the way you
know maybe graphine people heard about
that he had to do it he had to do it I'm
serious the first half of that statement
was absolutely perfect like this country
has a parasite that must be removed
without killing the host and I'm like
yes oh maybe it's sound vibration
that'll that'll kill the let's let's
write a song James we we we like the
Constitution we like the the principles
of this country and there is a an
occupying Force there's a parasite
within it how do we get it out without
destroying
ourselves so I I guess I got a question
if I may Matt I got a question for you
so for me uh an outsider more from a guy
that's a businessman entrepreneur I've
been in that world for the last 20 some
years last few years obviously have a
lot of interest in polic because I see
what's going on to the greatest nation
in the world I want to do my part to
protect it for the four kids that I have
what kind of progress did we make with
what happened with McCarthy so for
example were you when you first said you
got up and said this guy didn't keep the
promises he told me he was going to keep
he didn't do this he didn't do that he
didn't do this the $33 trillion of debt
did you actually
think your influence was going to be the
first time for him to get fired did you
think that was going to happen or were
you like oh this actually happened
oh my God I didn't want it to be this
bad I just wanted to scare him but no it
actually became a reality what were you
thinking when you first pushed it I've
been a bit despondent my last few years
in Congress because it feels like no
matter how much we make the Witnesses
look like fools in hearings they still
get the money to turn large features of
government against the American people
so I've come to believe that it's all
about the money it's about what you'll
pay for and what you won't and it's not
about just kind of brow beating people
into submission with really elaborate
committee hearings and in Washington
there's an ethic that you don't really
have to keep your promises about the
money because no one really means it
we've designed a system where the
president can blame the Congress the
Congress can blame the OM director the
Senate and the house can blame each
other we can all blame the bureaucrats
and at the end of the day everyone gets
reelected the debt grows and it's just
kind of a wink and a smile and in
January we did organize a core group
group of people to say this has to be
different and then we went around the
country I went on your show and said
this is how it's going to be different
we're going to do a budget and then
single subject spending bills that
address one thing at a time not every
disperate agency of government at once
and we're going to have like the
government spending increased 40% during
coid so we want to go back to preco
spending levels on like non-defense
discretionary spending at a minimum to
get the ball rolling and get momentum
for other broader deeper cuts and uh
when McCarthy sent us home for 6 weeks
without a budget when we knew we were
going to be pushed up against a deadline
with just yet another continuing
resolution advancing Joe Biden spending
and Nancy Pelosi's priorities uh I said
we can't do that anymore we at least
have to show that there's a consequence
to breaking your promises about spending
e even if only one time and even if only
for one man so I think that is an end
unto itself but now the job is not over
this is not the time to uncor the
champagne and Pat ourselves on the back
we have to get someone in that office
who will deliver on those precise
commitments and then we have to
demand that the Senate negotiate with us
not in the context of all these agencies
smooshed together but each of them
having to stand on their own merits so I
wouldn't say that that the deliverable
is more than the shock to the system
that Tim described uh but I do think
that there is a way to govern that
frankly I would hope would Outlast
Republican control of the House of
Representatives like when the Democrats
take over which they inevitably will at
some point in the waxing and waning of
politics why wouldn't you want a system
where people have to take votes and be
held accountable no matter who's in
charge that's how we ultimately win last
last night as I was going to bed I
walked to the window and I pulled up the
blinds and I looked up to the sky at the
first star and I wished as hard as a
human can wish that Donald Trump would
be speaker of the
house was it a shooting star it wasn't
so I don't know if it counts doesn't
count but no you were just you were just
a man with a hope with the Hope cuz I
because uh it's it's you you know Trump
represents a lot of this this energy of
finally people who felt disenfranchised
having someone fight for them I've heard
that so much the the first Trump rallies
I went to when he was running back in
2015 and 16 I met so many people who
said I'm not a republican I'm not
political I've never voted before and a
lot of what was being expressed to me by
younger people who were voting for him
was it finally feels like someone's
speaking to me and it's funny because I
remember that during Obama all these
young kids in Chicago were like he's
like me he's hoping he's changed then he
went and blew up a bunch of kids and I'm
like yeah okay I don't know about all
that so when Trump came around the first
time I'm like yeah I've heard it all
before you know kid and then come 2020
I'm like I think I'm going to vote for
this guy and now I know it's it's kind
of silly to expect Trump to be speaker
of the house but it's just aside from it
being very entertaining getting the
votes of people who voted to impeach him
will be a difficult political challenge
that's why I said I wish on a star it's
not like it's gonna happen what about
Jim Jordan he seems like the favorite
yeah I would say uh you know Jim's a
solid guy I think he would do a great
job as Speaker I don't think there would
be a single Republican in America who
would have McCarthy Nostalgia if we had
a speaker Jim
Jordan do you think there's resistance
to single subject spending bills on
obviously because they slip things into
the Omnibus there's resistance they
don't want to be found but that it's
going to take too long for 435 people to
read those it's just impossible
literally impossible but it's not
because in almost every state in the
country it happens I I've been in the
Florida legislature I am not looking at
a mirage every year we had a 9-week
session we figured out how much money
the state was bringing in based on how
many folks had had visited or spent
money here uh with our no income tax and
our sales tax based economy and then and
then we would just a little pitch for
the Sunshine
State and and then we would appropriate
to the agencies pursuant to that Topline
budget amount and that's how Most states
do it but in Washington because there's
no balance budget requirement there's no
reason to have any back stop to the
spending and there there are real
impacts of this when combined with what
I believe is overuse of a sanctions
regime right so look at what's happening
glob right now you have Brazil Russia
India China South Africa building their
system to pull the the global economy
away from the dollar they've added six
new countries in August including the
United Arab Emirates Saudi Arabia Iran
even Argentina a G20 economy here in the
Western Hemisphere uh you've got us news
saying that in 2023 the number one
global economic trend is dollarization
and then the way that we choose to
execute foreign policy is by telling
people that they can't use use the
dollar meanwhile we have to print 2.2
trillion more of them every single year
to fund a government that a lot of
people are questioning more and more
with good reason and that is not having
to stand for any type of itemized
specific review this is the plan this is
the path we are on and so when all these
mainstream media folks say that I'm
extreme and right-wing and Hardline they
never want to deal with the facts that
are that that are irrefutable and they
mean an entire generation of Americans
will own nothing you know as Bannon says
you'll be Russian surfs your whole life
unable to to have the American
experience that we deserve well I just
want to add people don't understand how
much trouble we are going to be having
very soon especially here in the United
States we have a political system that
benefits from fear and and ignorance and
it perpetrates both we're dealing with
such a corrupt system that they can't
find who left cocaine in the White House
they can't find who was on the Epstein
Client List they can't find the
surveillance footage of what hit the
Pentagon they can't do a placebo study
on the vaccines they can't do any of
that but if luren berbert is in the
crowd you bet that there's probably a HD
surveillance camera watching her right
now and if she is sitting here let me
know I kind of want to move my chairs
but but but but without that how do we
deal with this because the system is so
corrupt that I believe it left Donald
Trump ineffective in in so many ways how
do we fix this problem without just
voting once every four years what's the
solution
maybe we could ask somebody with
experience what it's like to have the
people that you've hired turn against
you oh yeah I just want to add one quick
thing since we don't have Trump I wonder
if there's anyone else that might have
that experience Luke they can do those
things they're pretending they can't and
they're intentionally lying to us of
course we just yeah I just have to say
it but uh James well you know Tim yes we
have that in
common um I'm I'm on my way here to
Miami late last night and I'm going to
the airport I'm exhausted and I get to
the TSA story I told this morning to Tim
and the TSA agent looks at look looks at
my ID and he looks at me there's always
that weird moment where I'm not sure I'm
sure do they hate me or do they really
like me and he looks at my ID he looks
at me and he goes they haven't killed
you
[Laughter]
yet and then which and then always
always the whisper I'm a huge fan and
then I say are you
whispering and Tim made the point this
morning which is I thought was profound
is the response that I should have gave
was no no not coming after me they're
coming going after you yeah because I
have an audience you know I have two you
know two million Twitter followers and
luckily supporters like you guys and I
have a
platform and Trump is in many ways to
borrow a business metaphor he's almost
like he's too big to fail I mean what he
what he St he's HCI at the bridge he is
the the I mean I I saw Leticia James
staring at him in the in the the
courtroom I don't know if you remember
that image of Leticia looking at him the
Attorney General in New York I mean he
represents something but it's the people
that don't have the following it's the
anonymous people that they're going to
come after people have to wake up to
that thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at
timcast.net thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time